[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle cet ensemble
de technologies a pour potentiel de
transformer notre quotidien mais aussi
influencer les acteurs géopolitiques les
appétits des poids lourds pour les
dernières découvertes sont de plus en
plus croissant comment se déroule
actuellement cette compétition à
l'échelle planétaire pour la suprématie
sur l'intelligence artificielle la
concurrence bat son plein actuellement
entre les états unis et la chine les
deux leaders actuels dans le
développement de l'ia washington test à
un rythme fou cessé de vos projets et
met des bâtons dans les roues de pékin
un adoptant des restrictions contre ces
géants du numérique
la chine elle se fixe pour objectif de
devenir le leader mondial dans l'ia et
s'investit pleinement dans son
développement
globalement plus de 50 états ont leur
propre stratégie visant à développer
l'intelligence artificielle moscou le
déclare par exemple comme l'une de ses
priorités
abu dhabi de son côté va jusqu'à créer
un ministère de l'est à une première
mondiale est le concurrent le plus
puissant de pékin et de washington et
l'union européenne
en plus du développement de
l'intelligence artificielle l'europe est
la première à adopter un règlement
définissant les principes d'utilisation
de l'ia pourtant à l'échelle mondiale il
n'y a toujours pas de cadre commun de ce
type de nombreuses questions éthiques
font toujours débat
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce que
représente cet ensemble de technologies
innovantes qui ont de plus en plus
tendance à se substituer à l'homme c'est
le blitz l'intelligence artificielle se
définit comme la simulation des
processus de l'intelligence humaine par
des machines et par des systèmes
informatiques pour se rapprocher le plus
possible du comportement humain à
l'intelligence artificielle a besoin
d'une quantité de données et d'une
capacité de traitement hors norme le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle ouvre incontestablement une
nouvelle ère dans différents domaines de
notre quotidien tels que les transports
les secteurs bancaire médical et
logistique robotisés parmi les avancées
accessible aujourd'hui figure la
reconnaissance faciale
l'assistant intelligent la voiture
autonome l'aide au diagnostic dans le
domaine militaire les ja se développe
aussi à vitesse grand v détection des
menaces aide à la décision militaire
entretien des matériels l'intelligence
artificielle promet une véritable
révolution technologique pour les armées
de terre de mer de l'air et de l'espace
parmi ce genre de nouveautés des drones
qui s'adapte en temps réel à
l'environnement ou des chars en partie
autonome
celui qui maîtrisera le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle deviendra le
maître du monde affirmait en 2017
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui l'enjeu
géopolitique de l'ia ne fait pas de
doute
plusieurs dizaines de pays ont leur
stratégie du développement de cette
technologie
or le combat principal pour la
suprématie sur l'intelligence
artificielle se joue actuellement entre
les états unis et la chine
si la chine interdit chez l utilisation
de google facebook twitter et what's app
les etats-unis eux mettent sur leurs
listes noires plusieurs géants
technologiques chinois aujourd'hui
pourtant les restrictions américaines
s'étende à d'autres pays
dès janvier 2020 l'exportation de
certains produits américains de l'ia est
limité pas étonnant d'ailleurs sachant
qu'un nombre de pays aspirent à
rattraper washington et pékin dans cette
course à l'intelligence artificielle la
russie la corée du sud et le japon par
exemple l'union européenne développe
aussi cette technologie chez elle mais
adopte en outre le cadrage juridique de
l'utilisation de liens au niveau mondial
élaboration de tels principes patine les
désaccords sont plus que nombreux sur
des questions éthiques de l'application
de l'ia alors quelles sont les
stratégies de pékin et de washington
pour le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle comment les autres états
cherche-t-il à réduire l'écart dans
cette course de haute technologie
pourquoi est il si difficile de parvenir
à un compromis sur les principes
d'utilisation de l'eia pour répondre à
ces questions nous rejoignons nicolas
maille président du think tank
international et futures society tfs
monsieur me yaï bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir
merci d'être là selon vladimir poutine
celui qui maîtrisera alia deviendra le
maître du monde
êtes vous d'accord avec lui alors c'est
un peu une remarque à l'emporte-pièce
cassetti quitte d'ailleurs du président
poutine
c'est plus compliqué que cela vous en
doutez bien mais au fond en caricaturant
je suis assez d'accord même si on est
pas tous tous les experts complètement
d'accord sur les termes des définitions
de liga alors dynamique la façon ça a
évolué dans les années à venir
j'en compte tombent tous d'accord pour
se dire que à partir on s'attaque à
l'intelligence au coeur de ce qui fait
la spécificité de l'humanité eh bien on
en fasse quelque chose de stratégique
pour l'avenir de notre société
l'intelligence et la capacité de prédire
d'optimiser et donc l'ati ratifie ciel
sa capacité de le faire à travers tous
les secteurs on parle vraiment là d'une
technologie général
d'ailleurs le
le chef de la majorité au sénat
américain n'a pas vraiment dit autre
chose
il ya quelques semaines quand même si
parler vitaux de la chine dont il a dit
que celui qui remportera la course
technologique du futur sera en fait le
leader économique de demain dans quelque
part ils répondaient plus tôt la chine
mais il parlait de la même chose les
etats unis sont aujourd'hui en tête de
la course mais la chine n'est pas en
reste vous venez de le dire pensez vous
que vers 2030 elles puissent rattraper
washington complètement complètement on
peut le dire dire ils sont là les moyens
ils sont la taille de marché captif
avec un marché de plus de 1,3 milliard
de consommateurs
ils ont une sphère d'influencé en asie
est maintenant en afrique qui leur
permettent de peser sur plus de la
moitié de l'humanité
ça fait un gros marché et donc ça permet
de rentabiliser les investissements
massifs et indispensable en matière de
calcul mais également en matière de
données que le carburant indispensable
pour entraîner ses modèles mathématiques
prédictif et puis ils ont maintenant une
capacité industrielle digital avec les
fameux bh à thé xx auxquels font face
les américains gars famille donc le
combat est lancé
ils investissent depuis des décennies
sur toute la chaîne de valeur de l'ia et
de la donnée jusqu'au semi conducteurs
et aux réseaux de télécoms donc on peut
dire maintenant qu'ils maîtrisent un
petit peu le poumon et le système
sanguin de l'ia et des eaux les
américains commencent à réagir
eric schmidt l'ancien pdg de google qui
a présidé la commission nationale de
l'ia et de la sécurité a vraiment tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé a appelé au
lancement de grands projets massifs
d'investissements ya dans le cas des
gros des méga plan de relance posco vide
juste pour donner un exemple le sénat a
passé la semaine dernière le and less
frontières acte qui prévoit un plan de
relance un plan d'investissement de 52
milliards de dollars dans le semi
conducteurs et de 60 milliards d'euros
celle dans la recherche donc la course
entre les deux superpuissances de l'ia
américaine et chinoise est clairement de
mise et ce n'est pas qu'une mauvaise
nouvelle ça peut être vecteur de
d'instabilité aussi mais il faut aussi
se dire que le mouvement avait été lancé
par le président de tram qui avaient
commencé à mettre en place des barrières
commerciales importantes vis-à-vis de la
chine sur les technologies les plus
avancées notamment en matière dia si le
temps un petit peu
angers s'est un peu assagi avec le
président buydens le fonds n'a pas
vraiment changé on est dans une course
au nord une relation de rivalités les
américains ont peur
merci beaucoup monsieur mila et nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur ce thème
merci encore les états unis franchissent
un nouveau pas dans le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle le 29 avril
l'armée américaine teste pour la
première fois son drone autonome doté du
système d'intelligence artificielle sky
borg
celui ci permet de contrôler le vol du
drone est de le maintenir dans son
domaine de vol de manoeuvrer l'appareil
est assurée la navigation et la sécurité
le tout de manière tout à fait autonome
cela fait plusieurs décennies que les
etats-unis mènent des recherches dans ce
domaine
or ce n'est qu'à partir de 2019 que le
développement de liga connaît un nouveau
souffle
cette année-là l'administration trump
publie la nouvelle stratégie américaine
en matière d'intelligence artificielle
elle appelle tout d'abord les agences
fédérales à faire plus d'investissements
dans l'ia en terme d'infrastructures il
leur sera aussi demandé d'aider les
chercheurs à accéder aux données
fédérales aux algorithmes est la
puissance de traitement
ensuite viennent la formation des cadres
l'élaboration des règles éthiques et
enfin la coopération internationale en
plus d'investir massivement dans ce
secteur washington s'appuie aussi sur
l'aide de ces géants du numérique
il s'agit principalement des gars femme
un acronyme qui désigne google apple
facebook amazon et microsoft les cinq
entreprises qui dominent actuellement le
marché du numérique
nous restons déterminés à collaborer
avec le gouvernement sur des projets
conformes à nos conditions de service à
nos politiques d'utilisation acceptable
et aux principes de l'ia premièrement
nous croyons la défense solide des états
unis et nous voulons que les gens qui
les défendent et accès aux meilleures
technologies du pays notamment de
microsoft
or malgré ses liens étroits avec les
géants du web
washington risque de perdre le
leadership dans la course à
l'intelligence artificielle c'est du
moins la conclusion d'un rapport récent
de la commission nationale de sécurité
américaines sur l'ia
la chine possède la puissance le talent
et l'ambition de dépasser des états unis
en tant que leader mondial de l'ia au
cours de la prochaine décennie si les
tendances actuelles ne change pas la
chine quant à elle ne cache pas ses
ambitions dans sa stratégie nationale du
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle pékin se fixe l'objectif de
devenir le leader mondial dans ce
domaine d'ici 2030 soutien à des
entreprises high-tech formation des
cadres construction de laboratoires et
de parcs de développement de l'ia en dix
ans la chine a déboursé plus de 30
milliards de dollars pour le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle et en plus de ce
financement généreux pékin coopère
étroitement avec les backs le petit
frère chinois dégâts femme qui comprend
baidu le google chinois alibaba le
cousin d'amazon le constructeur c'est au
mit et tencent le créateur de witt
chatte l'utilisation de l'ia permet
d'ores et déjà à pékin de retrouver des
criminels en fuite
grâce à l'emploi massif des caméras de
reconnaissance faciale
les travaux sont aussi menées dans le
domaine des transports et de la médecine
quant au domaine militaire pékin est
plutôt silencieux pourtant washington
l'accusent de produire et de vendre des
drones doté de l'intelligence
artificielle
en outre les fabricants d'armes chinois
vendent des drones présenté comme doté
d'une autonomie totale y compris celle
de mener des frappes ciblées mortel est
aujourd'hui washington lance une
véritable offensive contre les positions
de pékin sur le marché numérique
l'accusant de concurrence déloyale en
croire les états unis la chine procède
régulièrement au vol de technologies et
de propriété intellectuelle c'est ce que
révèle le fbi enquête sur un millier de
cas de vol de technologies par pékin à
cela s'ajoutent les accusations de
transfert de technologie forcer une
politique utilisée chou posément par
fait qu'un qui nous vend stand marchés à
des entreprises étrangères en échange de
secrets technologiques en accusant la
chine de vol washington utilise lui même
tout un arsenal de moyens pour contrer
les gens numérique chinois qui est pékin
dans le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle
sous l'administration preuve plusieurs
entreprises chinoises dont nous avait
elle faisait deux se retrouvent sur la
liste noire américaine
avec elle tout échange commercial est
interdit aux entreprises américaines
toutes celles qui utilisent des
technologies américaines dont
l'entreprise taïwanaise tsmc plus grand
fabricant mondial de semi conducteurs
risquent de se retrouver aussi frappé de
sanctions ou à weil est exclu en outre
du marché de la 5g aux états unis et de
celui de plusieurs de ses alliés qui ont
suivi le pas de washington en janvier
2021 washington a banni en plus huit
applications chinoises dont ali payent
plus que wallet hewitt chaque pays
appartenant respectivement à deux
mastodontes du numérique chinois alibaba
et tencent
aujourd'hui pourtant dans sa guerre aux
concurrents washington ne se limite pas
à la chine
l'année dernière le gouvernement
américain institue une règle visant à
limiter les exportations de technologies
basées sur l'intelligence artificielle
plus précisément la norme obligera
désormais les entreprises américaines à
obtenir une licence
s'ils veulent exporter certains
logiciels d'imagerie géospatiales à base
d'intelligence artificielle vers des
pays autres que le canada
quant aux états avec lesquels les
relations sont plus tendus l'approché
est encore plus dure toujours en 2020
washington restreint les exportations
des produits de haute technologie vers
les pays comme la russie la biélorussie
et le kazakhstan
alors quels sont les pays qui tentent de
défier la chine et les états unis dans
le développement de l'ia ou cette
technologie est elle déjà utilisé enfin
comment les différents pays propose-t-il
de résoudre les questions éthiques et de
réglementation de l'usaj de
l'intelligence artificielle
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
une utopie devenue réalité transports
économie médecine
il ne reste quasiment plus de secteurs
de notre vie quotidienne qui ne soit pas
lié à l'intelligence artificielle ces
dernières années l'intelligence
artificielle sortent de plus en plus des
laboratoires et touchent presque tous
les aspects de notre vie dans le domaine
de la sécurité
l'ia diminue considérablement les
risques et renforce la lutte contre la
criminalité
le système de reconnaissance faciale est
ainsi à détecter des comportements
suspects et des délinquants et à
retrouver des personnes égarées ou
désorientées aujourd'hui plus de 65 pays
dans le monde utilisent de tels systèmes
selon la fondation carnegie
les drones doté dia permettent quant à
eux de surveiller les frontières et les
côtes et d'accomplir des missions de
police et de gestion des catastrophes
naturelles
l'intelligence artificielle devient peu
à peu l'une des composantes cruciales du
domaine de la production
les usines se dotent de plus en plus de
robots qui travaillent main dans la main
avec les hommes selon la fédération
internationale de la robotique plus de
1,7 million de nouveaux robots
industriels sont installés dans des
usines à travers le monde et d'ici 2030
20 millions d'emplois industriels
pourrait disparaître à cause de
l'automatisation des tâches le domaine
du transport et déjà bouleversé par les
technologies de l'ia les véhicules
autonomes deviennent de plus en plus
répandue de 2018 à 2021
leur nombre a augmenté de 4 fois selon
gartner
l'ia permet en outre de réduire
drastiquement le nombre de blessés et de
morts dans les accidents causés par des
erreurs humaines
ces technologies certes aussi de cerveau
de la ville modélisant la demande de
transport public et réglant les feux de
circulation un autre secteur concerné
par l'ia et la santé des progrès
notables sont réalisés par exemple dans
le diagnostic du cancer qui se fait à
partir d'une analyse approfondie d'une
quantité massive de données sur le
patient il y a aussi les tchèques bottes
combiné qui aident à détecter les
maladies génétiques rares et
comprendre les symptômes le secteur
financier représente lui aussi un
environnement favorable à l'intégration
de l'intelligence artificielle les
systèmes dotés dia sont déjà utilisés
dans les domaines de l'analyse du risque
les prévisions de marché du conseil en
placement et de la gestion d'actifs
ils permettent en plus de réduire les
pertes à partir d'une analyse
approfondie du marché et d'améliorer la
relation client l'ia influence aussi la
manière dont on consomme l'information
la fonction d'assistant vocal fait ainsi
partie de notre quotidien
il n'ya presque plus de portable sans le
ciri d'apple ou l'assistant de google
ces aides sophistiqués ou par exemple
l'algorithme d'apprentissage automatisé
qui est capable d'appréhender le
comportement des utilisateurs et même de
prédire leur intention face aux enjeux
environnementaux
l'intelligence artificielle facilite les
modes de production durables
d'après l'étude du cabinet de conseil et
d'audit pwc et technologies de teddy a
pourrait réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 4% d'ici 2030 elles
sont capables d'optimiser les transporte
le fret de marchandises et la production
énergétique est très grande échelle dans
la course à l'intelligence artificielle
les deux favoris sont bien claires la
chine et les états unis
d'autres pays traîne derrière elle leur
retard ne cesse de s'accentuer les
outsideurs tente désespérément de
rattraper l'écart
le premier pays à avoir adopté une
stratégie nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle est en fait le canada en
mars 2010 est le japon la finlande et
les émirats arabes unis essaient de
suivre progressivement la fièvre de liga
a gagnent tous les continents sauf pour
l'instant l'afrique et l'asie centrale
aujourd'hui plus de 50 pays ont élaboré
des programmes spécifiques pour
développer cette technologie et leur
nombre ne cesse de croître
la plupart de ces stratégies ont un
point commun l'intelligence artificielle
n'est pas seulement une direction à
explorer mais carrément une priorité
nationale le ton est donné en 2017 par
le président russe vladimir poutine
s'est positionné
l'intelligence artificielle incarne
l'avenir non seulement pour la russie
mais pour l'humanité tout entière
elle recèle des possibilités immenses et
des menaces difficilement prévisibles or
ce n'est qu'en 2019 que la russie a
rejoint formellement la course et
dévoile son programme pour lire sa
priorité est tout d'abord de rattraper
le retard par rapport au champion vers
2024 puis devenir un des leaders
mondiaux dans ce domaine et cela vers
un objectif ambitieux car pour l'instant
les infrastructures nécessaires
n'existent quasiment pas en russie
oh non les super ordinateurs par exemple
en 2021
seuls deux machines russes entrent au
classement des 100 meilleures mondiales
contre 226 chinoise et centrait
américaine tout cela devra changer la
stratégie nationale prévoit la création
d'un réseau de nouveau superordinateur
et de neuf centres d'études dans le pays
pourtant il existe un domaine
d'application de l'intelligence
artificielle ou la russie figurent déjà
parmi les leaders ce sont des armements
intelligent une multitude de modèles les
plus improbables ont été développés par
moscou ces dernières années des sous
marins autonomes porteurs de givre
nucléaire des munitions qui résiste aux
brouillages décembre deux missiles
autoguidés des robots de combat des
systèmes intelligents de contrôle
tactique et même le char autonome armata
sa version classique est déjà utilisé
par l'armée russe est la version
autonome vient de subir des essais en
mars
le char a pu neutraliser sa cible sans
participation de l'équipage vers 2025 la
russie projette de robotiser 30% de ses
armements
de fait nombre de pays mis sur le
développement de liens militaires plutôt
que civil pour certains c'est une
affaire lucrative comme la turquie ou
israël qui sont devenus des exportateurs
majeurs de drones de combat autonome
pour d'autres c'est une question de
sécurité nationale comme pour le royaume
uni qui a investi gros dans
l'intelligence artificielle militaire
pour rester à la hauteur des menaces
tout cela coûte cher mais les
gouvernements espèrent que ce savoir
faire militaire donnera aussi une
impulsion au secteur de l'ia civile
espoir récemment corroborées par une
coopération improbable au moyen-orient
la société de défense israélienne rafael
et la compagnie émirati g 42 viennent de
joindre leurs forces pour commercialiser
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
secteur civil
une coopération qui démarre en octobre
dernier les centres d'études isralien et
émirati signa un mémorandum pour oeuvrer
ensemble sur les technologies
intelligentes
les émirats sont d'ailleurs dans
l'avant-garde dans la région c'est le
premier pays du monde à créer un
ministère de l'intelligence artificielle
est une université de lille
reste à voir si les gros budget vont
aider les pays arabes à combler le vide
technologique entre temps d'autres états
à chummun leurs défauts et les
transforme en atout comme l'inde en
manque d'infrastructures et d'expertisé
elle propose ses services en terrain
d'essai de nouvelles technologies l'un
deux représentants terrain de jeu
parfait pour les entreprises et les
institutions du monde entier pour
développer des solutions évolutives qui
peuvent être facilement implémenté dans
le reste des économies émergentes et en
développement
une offre qui commence peu à peu à
séduire de 2015 à 2019 le secteur privé
indien de l'intelligence artificielle
connaît un boom d'investissement en
revanche en chiffres absolus l'inde
reste loin derrière des pays comme les
etats-unis et la chine 1,2 milliard de
dollars investis dans le secteur privé
de l'ia en 2019 contre 47 milliards aux
états unis et 7 milliards en chine pour
les pays émergents rattraper le retard
s'annonce une tâche difficile
entre temps les pays développés passe
déjà à la vitesse supérieure ainsi au
japon
les technologies de l'ia sont devenu une
banalité dans presque tous les secteurs
économiques mais aussi dans la
gouvernance et la gestion sociale en
europe l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle reste plus limité mais
plusieurs centres de savoir-faire
émergent déjà comme l'allemagne la
france ou encore la région nordique
ces succès permettent à l'union
européenne de tenir bon à la troisième
place dans la course derrière pékin et
washington
or le
se focalise aussi sur l'autre aspect de
la gestion de l'intelligence
artificielle la réglementation de ces
usages en avril la commission européenne
dévoile son ambitieux projet de
réglementation pour l'intelligence
artificielle le texte interdit certains
usages de lee a déjà pratiqué ailleurs
dans le monde
système de crédit social surveillance
généralisée manipulation d'autres cas
classés à haut risque sont fortement
encadrée identification biométrique en
lieu public systèmes intelligents
électriques ou routier assistance aux
décisions pour les juges et d'autres
s'il est adopté ce document fera de
l'union européenne un vrai pionnier dans
le domaine de l'éthique de l'ia puisque
aucun cadre légal international n'existe
encore pour ce secteur
cependant nombre de questions restent
tout de même irrésolu en effet ici un
robot tueur prend par lui même la
décision d'anéantir une cible qui en
portera la responsabilité et comment
protéger les civils d'une éventuelle
erreur de jugement en l'absence de
règles claires des appels à interdire
les robots militaires se multiplient
comme celui de la coalition au stop qui
leur robot se lancer en 2013 à
l'initiative de human rights watch
il comprend plus de 80 ong du monde
entier pour d'autres
la solution est de limiter l'autonomie
des robots les humains ne peuvent pas
déléguer aux machines la décision
d'utiliser la violence
les décisions de tués de blessés et de
détruire doivent rester du côté humain
ce sont des humains qui applique la loi
et sont obligés d'obéir
pourtant tous les états ne sont pas
d'accord les états unis par exemple
refusent d'encadrer et l'intelligence
artificielle militaire de peur de
freiner son développement
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
de nouveau nicolas mas et fondateur et
président du think tank international
les futures society ou tfs monsieur me
yaï qu'est ce que l'union européenne
doit faire pour rejoindre les rangs des
états unis et de la chine dans le
domaine de l'iard l'union européenne
doit à tout prix
unifier son marché et produire un énorme
effort industriels pour faire émerger
des champions industriels
l'ue est une puissance scientifique
c'est une puissance en matière
d'innovation en matière de talents
humains le problème son retard vient de
ses incapacités en matière industrielle
endroit la rater la première étape du
capitalisme digital et les grandes
plateformes et elle risque de rater la
seconde marche du capitalisme dit
cognitif solide l'ia alors sur le papier
sa taille de marché et critique avec
près de 500 millions de consommateurs
mais en fait ce marché est trop
fragmentée trop de langues différentes
trop de barrières et donc il ya un gros
effort à l'oeuvre de la part de la
commission européenne soutenue par la
plupart des états membres que porte
comme il s'est retiré breton pour créer
un vrai marché unique digital c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
l'union européenne cherche à refonder
son alliance transatlantique avec les
américains essaient de voir dans quelle
mesure il ya une communauté de valeurs
il faut laisser les produits et les
services circuler et donc quelles autres
mesures il faut mettre des barrières
pour que certains des effets pervers de
l'économie des réseaux sociaux par
exemple ne pénètre pas trop profondément
et certains effets pervers de la 2de
l'absence quasiment totale de
concurrence entre grandes plateformes
empêche l'émergence de grandes
plateformes européennes donc à cet
équilibre entre coopération et rivalités
transatlantique
c'est vraiment ces deux choses là bien
géré ça bien gérer les relations avec la
chine bien gérer l'ouverture vis-à-vis
de la russie un premier temps et surtout
unifié ce marché digital pour en créer
un marché digital unique c'est
fondamental sens à l'europe de pourra
servir que 2 2 on va dire de colonies
numérique aux etats-unis c'est ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est une
colonie numérique des états unis par
ailleurs l'union européenne et peut
devenir pionnière dans le domaine de la
réglementation de l'intelligence
artificielle la commission européenne
développe un tel document en ce moment
pensez vous qu'on ait éventuellement
besoin d'une régulation universel de
l'ia un oui complètement
d'ailleurs il ya une convention qui
porte sur un traité international qui
est en développement sur l'intersection
entre lille et les droits fondamentaux
humains est en discussion développement
aujourd'hui au conseil de l'europe à ne
pas confondre avec la commission
européenne et de et le conseil de
l'europe
il ya la russie c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui va loin et large dans le
continent eurasiatique
pour moi cette régulation de l'ia elle
est indispensable parce qu est associée
au modèle d'affaires des réseaux sociaux
de l'économie de l'attention l'économie
prédictive
c'est hier remet en cause certaines de
nos libertés les plus fondamentales la
vie privée bien sûr la discrimination
mais j'ai envie de dire jusqu'à la
liberté de penser à partir d'un certain
âge groupe vous connaissent mieux que
vous ne vous connaissez vous même que
vos proches qui ne connaissent vous même
alors se pose la question du libre
arbitre de la liberté de pensée et en
laissant le marché s'auto gérer on
risque vraiment de broyer les libertés
individuelles de nos enfants donc je
pense que cette régulation elle et elle
est important pour faire face à ces
nouvelles vulnérabilités qu'il faut
aussi se dire que le monde cyber il est
plein de risques que déploiement de ces
algues au rythme d'une nouvelle
génération dans ce monde cyber sans
régulation risquent encore une fois
comme j'ai dit avant de déstabiliser la
sécurité internationale donc il faut
trouver les moyens que des dynamiques
criminelle mafieuse terroristes et
parfois des rivalités entre les grandes
puissances
des plans salle gorée dans un monde
cyber non gérés ne donne lieu à des
engrenages inferno qui pourrait aller
vers la cyber confidentialité et demain
d'actualité dont cyber donc violence
donc il faut penser demain d'ici 2030
2040 un traité de non-prolifération pour
éviter la guerre tout en assurant à tous
les pays un accès équitable aux
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
ça va pas être facile on a vu qu'avec
l'histoire du nucléaire militaire ça n'a
pas été facile mais il faut absolument
créer le cadre pour y arriver c'est ce
qui nous attendait dans les prochaines
décennies
merci beaucoup et nicolas miailhe je
rappelle vous êtes président du think
tank international les futures society
tfz tfs merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage dans
notre émission cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]